aber ich glaube ich mal wie macht man
nochmal zäune hallo mein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video ihr seht es wahrscheinlich
schon im titel eingeblendet minecraft
wir lagern heute mal ein bisschen dafür
bin ich hier in meine bieter welt
gegangen und ihr seht vielleicht schon
am text gepäck und an so ein paar
anderen kleinigkeiten
ja die welt befindet sich quasi gerade
in der minecraft version 1.8 uns wenn
ich in der beta 1.8 sondern in der
vollversion 1.8 das heißt sie ist jetzt
quasi konvertiert worden müssen tun sein
von mir gerade aber ich glaube ich
strukturiert das video mal einfach so
ein bisschen nebenbei wollte ich hier so
ein paar kleinigkeiten machen wie
beispielsweise diese türen damit die
richtig stehen wieder und so weiter und
so fort das werdet ihr gleich auch schon
sehen was ich alles so nebenbei mache
ich wollte einfach nur kurz darüber
reden wie so als mannschaft etwas länger
nicht kam mehrere monate einem
historiker ist ich wollte einfach mal so
ein bisschen stellung nehmen hier ein
paar kleinigkeiten ändern sagen woran es
lag also würde ich sagen ich verliere
gar nicht großartig zeit sondern es lag
wirklich einfach daran dass ich enorme
probleme mit meinem minecraft account
mal wieder hatte ich will das jetzt
natürlich nicht komplett darauf schieben
dass sich nicht in ihr account gekommen
bin und auch wieder 10.000 jahre lang
mit dem modell support in kontakt stand
sondern es war halt wirklich so dass ich
ja ich stand 10.000 jahre lang mit dem
magic support in kontakt
ich hatte so ein ähnliches problem ja
schon mal und zwar dass ich nicht in
meinen minecraft account reingekommen
bin weil sich irgendwer irgendwie den
namen geklärt hat und ich mich lengerich
eingeloggt habe dann wurde ich irgendwie
mal gehackt und ein anderer typ hatte
mein account es gab noch andere stories
wo ich mir mal die e mail adresse nicht
mehr merken konnte und dann habe ich
mein passwort vergessen und das passwort
ging aber über die mailadresse und in
die medien gekommen weil das irgendwie
eine ganz alte e mail adresse von mir
bei gmx oder so gewesen ist und ich
wusste überhaupt nicht mehr wie dies und
der mod support konnte mir dann halt
auch nicht wirklich so weiter helfen
beziehungsweise durften die halt auch
nicht wirklich weil die ja dadurch quasi
jeder hätte einfach reingehen können und
sagen kann ich habe meine emailadresse
vergessen ich bin der typ das war auf
jeden fall alles so ein bisschen ein
kleiner hackmack und jetzt habe ich halt
alles endlich wieder ich habe das jetzt
eine neue e mail adresse gemacht die
jetzt auch nicht öffentlich ist also hab
das jetzt alles so ein bisschen geregelt
dass das jetzt auf jeden fall nicht mehr
passieren sollte das heißt auf jeden
fall in zukunft kommt wieder ab und zu
minecraft ich wollte auch bald mit marx
allee das verrate ich noch nicht also es
geht jetzt nicht um minecraft mode
sondern um so eine andere sache in bezug
auf minecraft aber das möchte ich noch
nicht verraten dass hier wollte ich auch
schon die ganze zeit mal machen das
einfach diese teile da so komplett hoch
gehen weil das einmal so komplett wie
gmx de chile in database eigentlich
mache ich dieses mal schafft beta labs
player auch immer am dienstag wenn ihr
das video seht ist glaube ich gerade
donnerstag und eigentlich schneide ich
ja auch nicht und das wird gerade macht
das heißt ich geh mal kurz kennen
eigentlich schneide ich ja auch nicht so
wirklich beziehungsweise habe diesen
einen moment wo ich im video sagte jetzt
ich bereue schnitt mehr am start aber
ich habe mir jetzt gedacht für dieses
kurze info video hier kann ich das auf
jeden fall mal kurz machen
die fackeln hier wollte ich ihn noch mal
so ein bisschen anders verteilen erstmal
auch sorry dafür dass ich mich
vielleicht so ein bisschen kränklich
anhöre das liegt einfach daran weil
hatte ich ja schon mal gesagt es war
karneval in köln und in köln wird es
wirklich immer sehr exzessiv gefeiert
dass man dort auf jeden fall den ganzen
tag auch draußen steht und das war auch
wunderbares wetter also es waren zwölf
grad und so und die sonne hat geschienen
das war schon cool aber entsteht dann
natürlich auch immer mit hoch kann mit
der hose da und im ganzen bus und
deswegen wurde ich halt einfach bin ich
jetzt erkrankt erkältet und ihr müsst
wissen ich fliege
in
50 minuten nach berlin ich fange wieder
früher ein video vor produzieren und hab
mir dann einfach gedacht der joh
ich habe das jetzt heute endlich
hingekriegt wieder minecraft das ist mal
wieder läuft die muss wirklich sagen ich
hab ich da jetzt natürlich nicht die
letzten monate jeden tag darum gekümmert
sondern das war einfach ein chat verlauf
mit mojo bzw e mail verlauf der dann
teilweise mal so zeit lücken drin hatte
von zwei wochen oder so und dann musste
ich jetzt quasi letztendlich ein
komplettes minecraft löschen aber
überhaupt nicht dran gedacht dass
irgendwie hier nicht zu sichern sondern
meditation zu merken und beim staaten
daran zu denken und auf einmal stand das
an meinem start sowie der bisher muss
kommentiert werden und dann wollte jetzt
abbrechen aber dann habe ich halt kein
bock dass die welt dann irgendwie
komplett kaputt geht deswegen habe ich
dann einfach gesagt ja kommen dann
kommen konvertiert das und dann alle die
nicht wissen was konvertieren heißt ich
habe das hier angefangen in der
minecraft beta 1 punkt irgendwas und
jetzt befinde ich mich quasi in der
normalen vollversion aber es läuft jetzt
auch endlich mal flüssig so also
eigentlich hat auch ein paar gute sachen
und alles was ich jetzt noch nicht
entdeckt habe in dieser welt ist jetzt
quasi einfach sage ich mal mit der neuen
version generiert worden und alles was
hier noch rum schild so um meinen
standpunkt und so dass da oben das ist
doch alles die alte version also es ist
eigentlich gar nicht mal so schlimm hier
den berg wollte ich ja auch noch mal
auffüllen also es gibt noch ein paar
sachen die ich machen muss ich habe auch
schon überlegt das ganze projekt hier in
den in einen live stream zu verpacken
weil ich jetzt so ein youtube live frank
vip bums status habe das wäre mit
sicherheit auch eine möglichkeit gewesen
dieses projekte weiterzuführen ich
wollte jetzt aber einfach mal euch das
entscheiden lassen also ich weiß dass
dieses projekt hier natürlich nicht so
krass was warum habe ich das gemacht das
ist typisch kong kraft weiß nicht was er
machen soll und packt einfach in so
einen bums hier rein
aber ich glaube ich mal wie macht man
nochmal zäune
ich hatte wirklich überlegt dass hier
einfach ein live stream projekt zu
machen
aber da das wirklich so viele leute noch
feiern und so viele auch diese videos
von minecraft hier noch anschauen weiß
ich nicht ob das die richtige
entscheidung ist also ein livestream
dann kann man sich dann natürlich immer
noch einmal angucken weil ich keinen
bock habt eine ungeschnittene live
stream der dann eine stunde geht oder so
auf meinem kann
hochzuladen deswegen habe ich mir halt
einfach so überlegt okay fragt immer die
leute deswegen habt jetzt quasi zwei
möglichkeiten wollt ihr entweder dass
das projekt hier im live stream projekt
wird das heißt dass ich wie das die
softbox eigentlich so gelb kann ich dir
nicht mehr so ein bisschen so besser
oder wollt ihr entweder dass das ganze
hier live stream projekt wird oder soll
das ganze auf youtube fortgeführt werden
schreibt mir dazu am besten eure meinung
in die kommentare sonst mache ich das ja
immer so dass man quasi einfach ein wort
schreiben kann aber schreibt mir mal
bitte jetzt einfach in die kommentare
mit einer begründung sage ich mal wofür
ihr für die jeweilige sache seit weil
ich bin mir da selber unschlüssig und
würde einfach mal gerne wissen was ihr
dazu sagt was ihr davon haltet all wie
mache ich denn freunde jetzt die sache
ist halt auch dass ich dieses projekt
hier ungern jetzt noch drei vier monate
irgendwie wöchentlich hochladen möchte
weil nicht mit max hat ganz andere pläne
derzeit habe was youtube angeht und auch
was minecraft angeht deswegen wäre es
halt echt cool wenn ihr mal einfach in
die kommentare schreiben könnte was ihr
davon haltet was wir aus diesem dreck
machen würde ob ich einfach so man
minecraft hochladen soll ob ich das hier
vielleicht nur alle zwei drei wochen
hoch laden soll ob ich dann vielleicht
einfach mal einer halben stunden fahrt
machen soll wisst ihr was leute ich
glaube ich würde jetzt mal kurz rüber in
die version dass ich jetzt nicht
schneide weil sich das ja auch einige
mal wieder gewünscht hatten
also wir befinden uns in minecraft
komplett ungeschnitten gerade das was
ich jetzt auf jeden fall machen wollte
war noch ein bisschen holz holen weil
ich dann daran immer so ein bisschen
nicht so viel am start habe aber das
passt ganz gut weil dann kann ich
nebenbei noch ein ganz hinten lagen
ich weiß nicht ob hier vorne irgendwann
setzt den hingefallen ist weil dem
bräuchten wird da vorne damit er wieder
so ein baum wächst
ich würde auch ganz gern mal einfach
auch eine deckung gehen da hinten
irgendwo rum dümpeln oder irgendwie so
aber jetzt fällt jetzt auch keinen satz
gegen darunter glaube ich also da das
ist und zum los ging also dass hier geht
dann nicht runter aber ich will auch
nicht noch mehr stelzen
eigentlich muss ich dann auf stelzen den
bauern und es wird schon wieder nach
mitternacht nach ich weiß nicht ja ich
weiss nicht also ich lad dass hier
gerade einerseits wirklich hochwald sind
wieder geklappt hat mit minecraft
endlich und anderer es ist noch nicht
wieder nacht und andererseits weil sich
das auch wirklich einige gewünscht
hatten also viele meinten mach mal
wieder hier den minecraft und luca wir
vermissen das voll und pulli wann kommt
die denn das sind juli liegt nämlich
gerade einfach daran dass ich mit marvin
das ist der den ihr vielleicht aus den
kohleblock scannt dass ich mit dem noch
von abschließenden teil machen wollte
sage ich mal also ich wollte jetzt nicht
dass dies das ende juli einfach
zurückschlägt und wären diese blogs
serie bei vier pars belassen haben und
danach war es das nun quasi sondern eher
mal wirklich beide gesagt okay das lief
eigentlich ganz neues so die
kommunikation darüber geklagt dass ich
ganz cool
lasst uns einfach sagen wir machen aber
noch ein teil so abschließend und das
ist jetzt quasi das was cool treppe bank
you man das ist nämlich auch wieder die
sache in der alten wieso kommt man nicht
einfach so hin lesen und dann war alles
in ordnung
also das liegt derzeit bezug auf
ökologie einfach daran dass wir noch so
ein teil davon machen wollen und danach
mit der ökologie zurückgesandt und ja
also was nicht quasi die letzten monate
gemacht habe war ja so ein bisschen mein
content mehr in die richtung wieder
leicht verändert weil wir das einfach
mehr spaß gemacht hat weil das auch
schneller geht zu schneiden als meine
gaming zusammenschnitte und zeit mir
wirklich in letzter zeit sehr sehr
wichtig war auch ihr tipp und fisch
einfach wegen studium und es gab so viel
und ich bin jetzt auch schon fast fertig
mit studieren überlegt mal ich weiß noch
wie ich habe angefangen gaming videos zu
schneiden als ich in meine alte buhlen
meine bude in köln gezogen
nächstes mal vielleicht 40 millionen
stockwerk runter ich kann nicht mehr
sprinten und da ja jetzt verfalle ich
wieder voll in diesem nostalgie zustand
und holt gleich wahrscheinlich wieder
also ich wollte jetzt gar nicht so in
diese schiene reinfallen von wegen er ja
für ihn alles glaube ich wüsste dass ich
dankbar bin und was geschieht jetzt auch
wieder rein waren ja keine ahnung also
ich wollte wirklich einmal mit diesem
video zeigen hey tag die welt existiert
noch minecraft ich wieder da bin
das heißt wieder da ist sie da also ich
kann wieder zocken so an wenn ihr ideen
habt was ich machen kann dieser blöde
kümpel da der ist seit 1 also wenn ihr
wisst was ich machen kann mit diesem
projekt ob sie live im projekt werden
soll was ich dann ab und zu mal mache
oder nicht oder real life projekt cool
locker macht wähler zu minecraft bohei
ja dann schreibt er dass einfach die
kommentare das schaf lasse ich mal da
vorne stehen
setzlinge haben wir glaube ich keine
märkte drop bekommen
sind da noch welche nichts mehr und ich
hoffe dass euch das ich euch jetzt ein
bisschen belehren konnte mit den
informationen die so lange nicht kam
ich sollte immer noch eben schnell was
essen beziehungsweise mir ein brot
machen ich werde gar nicht
ich musste es ach ich wollte dass
bereits im kornfeld ja auch noch darüber
da vorne hin packen gott leute ich
schaue mal einfach eben schon ab da
vorne vielleicht noch ein weizen
gewachsen ist können wir noch im brot
reifen ist gewachsen
ich glaube ich ja ist gewachsen was ich
dann geht auch gleich die sonne passend
unter und ich kann mir nicht mein punkt
bleiben
was mache ich denn jetzt wieder sagen ja
ich wollte euch einfach mal sagen hier
was hier abgeht also viele hatten
gemeinde in minecraft ist woran liegt
das und ich wollte einfach nicht alle
zwei wochen video machen ja ich wohl
wieder gehackt und ja wieder einer und
dadurch fühlen sich die leute ja auch
nur angetrieben das weiterzumachen und
ich weiß nicht wollte der fand wollte
das ist nicht so große wellen schlägt
deswegen nicht so einfach gemacht also
wenn ihr daran hab ich habe schon oft
genug gesagt schreib mir eure meinung in
die kommentare
ich mache mir jetzt noch eben hier ein
brot mal eben so da haben wir ein büro
dann esse ich das jetzt eben mal schnell
dann sehen wir dass nach vorne
die sonne auch schon sich wieder nach
unten bewegt genau das war es jetzt hier
vom videomanager abonnieren
wenn euch das ganze gefallen hat und ihr
wirklich sagt hey luca ist cool dass man
zurück ist anlass mal nen fetten like da
dann sehe ich ja auch wie viele das
wollen und ich meinen desto mehr leute
da wirklich bock drauf haben warum in
der früheren version kommt man da nicht
zwischendurch laufen deswegen hab ich
mich dann immer so hingestellt hat keine
ahnung ich kann ja auch mal hässliche
sein einladen muss
unter den server holen ist wayne wie
gesagt schreibt mir eure meinung in die
kommentare
und ich lege mich jetzt ins bett ich
kann nachts schlafen aber die sonne
schon fast untergegangen jetzt noch
nicht okay jetzt okay ich liege im bett
meine damen und herren
deswegen würde ich sagen das war es
jetzt auch vom video hier die gerade
schon gesagt wenn ihr bock darauf habt
dann lasst mir einfach ein like da und
ich würde sagen schaltet eure meinung in
die kommentare ich wollte mich einfach
mal kurz melden darf und die minecraft
welt auf jeden fall noch existiert viele
angesagte jetzt gelöscht wegen dumm und
sohn ein ich glaube ich war selber am
besten was damit passiert ist und das
war einfach weil ich mich in minecraft
gekommen bin und wie das die ganze zeit
geregelt haben mit motto bleib ich will
gar nicht mehr weiter lagern ja das war
es hier vom video hat herein macht es
gut